session 3 high content imaging
applications to tissue engineering
i'm kyle quinn assistant professor at
the university of arkansas and i'll be
one of the moderators for this session
it's my great pleasure to introduce our
first speaker of the session
dr melissa scala who's one of my
favorite people to run into at
biomedical conferences
melissa is a professor of biomedical
engineering at the university of
wisconsin-madison and runs her lab
at the mortgage institute for research
there
over there she's had previous stops at
wisconsin duke and vanderbilt
and she's one of the pioneers in
developing and applying label-free
quantitative imaging tools to assess
cell metabolism
she's been doing some exciting work in
using these tools with patient-derived
cancer organoids which has some
important implications for
for drug development and clinical
planning so in contrast to
much of the work that we've seen at this
conference
melissa takes on this challenging task
of quantitative imaging using only
autofluorescence and other endogenous
sources of contrast
recently she's extended this work to
look at immune cell activation but i
should let melissa tell you about these
things
so let's queue up her presentation
hello my name is melissa scala and i'm
an investigator at the mortgage
institute for research
also a professor at biomedical
engineering at the university of
wisconsin-madison
today i'm going to talk about metabolic
imaging of cellular heterogeneity and
patient-derived cancer organoids
so when i think about cancer i think
about the single cell heterogeneity and
how that can affect
treatment response and tumor growth and
this
uh video here is a simulation that um
nicely encompasses that idea so each of
these dots
is representing a different cell and
each color represents a different
phenotype of that cell so that could be
surface marker expression metabolism
proliferation rate anything and so what
we're going to do here is see how the
tumor grows
and how these subclones of tumor cells
grow and how they respond to treatment
so here we have the tumor growing over
you know several days here
and now we have treatment which you know
could be anything radiation chemotherapy
targeted therapy
and you see that this treatment is very
effective at reducing the number of
cells to very few
compared to what we had at the beginning
but now what you see is this sort of
subclonal growth so there's a few
types of cells that are thriving
with this treatment so the treatment is
still happening but the cells are still
growing
and they're actually outgrowing what
they were contributing to the original
tumor so this is what we think about
when we think about single cell
heterogeneity in cancer
and this is important because we see it
in the clinic we see people who
initially respond and have
almost undetectable cancer and then
after prolonged treatment
we see a new type of tumor growing that
is
more treatment resistant more lethal
more aggressive
and what we've done here is select for a
subpopulation of cells that is perhaps
more lethal than the original tumor
cells that were
providing some portion of
selective pressures in the tumor so this
nicely illustrates the idea that
heterogeneity between tumor cells
contributes to treatment resistance
and currently we don't consider this in
clinical treatment and
mostly this is because we don't have the
tools to do so so we look at things like
ct or mri
to understand how a tumor is growing or
shrinking shrinking but we don't think
about
single cell heterogeneity so what i'd
like to do
is use microscopy to address this issue
because microscopy as you know
is really great for single cell
resolution we're not doing it in vivo in
humans except for you know some surface
cancers
so we have to be a little more creative
about how we're going to assess single
cell heterogeneity
using microscopy so what we do is use
tumor organoids
and these are growing in popularity
because they're a great model system
to measure single cell response within a
patient mapped
sample so what we do is we get a biopsy
or a surgical sample
from a patient and we just take the
tissue and we
mechanically dissociate it that means we
cut it up with uh scissors
and then we embed it in a 3d collagen
matrix so it's kind of like a jello
you know looking thing gelatin kind of
and then we put media over the top so
what we're trying to do here
is mimic the body and try to fool these
tumor cells into behaving as they would
in the body
and the benefit here for us as
microscopists is that these are small
things so these tumor organoids are only
about
200 sometimes they get bigger few
hundred microns in diameter
so we can assess them with things like
two photon microscopy and we can image
all the way through
the tumor organoids in this way and so
this
advancements in tumor organoids have
been really beneficial for us
in assessing single cell heterogeneity
and previous groups have really done a
fantastic job characterizing these tumor
organoids it's a
popular area of study and they've shown
that genetic expression levels in the
organoids closely
mimics the host tumor the heterogeneity
and cell types of the host tumor
maintained in the organoids
and there are some other studies looking
at functional imaging within these tumor
organoids and
i'm happy to see this is a growing area
of investigation
because i think it's a great way that we
can contribute as
imaging experts to this great need in
oncology
so in my lab we're trying to do things
sort of on
two ends of the spectrum we're thinking
about clinical impact so we want to
develop
high throughput drug screening
technologies on a single patient level
so that we can inform clinical treatment
decisions because as you know each tumor
is different each patient responds
differently to treatment
so these match tumor organoids are a
nice way to assess that before we
actually treat the patient
but we work on some tumors that don't
have very good
drug treatment options like pancreatic
cancer
so we want to also use the same system
of
using patient derived samples to really
understand what drugs we should go after
in clinical trials later on so what
we're doing is obtaining a tumor biopsy
or surgical sample
and we replicate the sample as much as
possible into as many wells as we are
able to given the size of the sample and
its viability
and then we perform optical metabolic
imaging which i'll talk about later but
it is a two-photon autofluorescence
imaging technique that we use to assess
single cell response to treatment and
then we quantify the single cell
response to treatment and use some
population density modeling
to understand how heterogeneity might
contribute to treatment response or
resistance and from this we're hoping we
can identify an optimal treatment
regimen that really improves the life of
the patient
and if not improves the life of the
patient in this particular context we're
also
testing many different potential
candidates for clinical
trials um so that we can get those to
patients as soon as possible
so i mentioned we're looking at
metabolic response in the tumor cells
and so you know you could
measure anything you want to understand
treatment response and tumor organoids
and we chose metabolism because we know
that
metabolism is one of the early changes
in the cell in response to treatment so
this gives us an early measure of drug
efficacy
we also know that cell metabolism can
capture non-genetic
adaptation and drug resistance it's not
very well captured by current techniques
so it offers
some ability to fill a niche that's
currently not met
and we know that within the tumor you
know there's selective pressures
that create metabolic micro environments
that really do contribute to tumor head
originating so we can capture that
with our techniques so what exactly are
we
measuring we're measuring
autofluorescence from two metabolic
coenzymes
so nadh and fad are
ubiquitous we even find them in bacteria
so they're
very common um electron donor and
acceptor
they're involved for example nadh is
involved in greater than 300 reactions
in the cell both in the cysosol and in
the mitochondria
and we're just highlighting a few here
to give you an idea of what we're
looking at so
first of all nadh and nadph are
spectrally overlapping and they have
overlapping fluorescent
properties so we refer to them
collectively as nadph
and fad and fmn are also closely related
in their spectral properties so this is
a combination of both of those
molecules so you can see we produce you
know
nadh and consume nadh in various
metabolic reactions
um and what we do is take the ratio of
nadh to fad
and call this the optical redox ratio
which provides us
information on how oxidized or reduced
the overall
cell is and this has become very um
useful in many different studies for
measuring whether a tumor is malignant
or not whether it's aggressive or not
and we use it to measure drug response
we're also measuring the fluorescence
lifetime of these molecules so that's
the time
that the molecule is in the excited
state before decaying back down to the
ground state
and this is useful because nadh and fad
have two very distinct conformations so
for example nadh when it's free it folds
up on itself like this
and when it binds to a protein it
extends and that creates
two very distinct lifetimes due to some
self-crunching here
so the free nadh has a short lifetime
the protein bound nadh has a long
lifetime
and the converse is true for fad so when
we measure the fluorescence lifetime
we're really measuring
the pools of nadh or fad that are in a
free
or a protein bound state and this gives
us an idea of binding activity of these
molecules
it's very sensitive again to malignancy
and drug response
so as i mentioned before we're using two
photon microscopy
and we're using time correlated single
photon counting so we're building up
this decay curve for each pixel in the
image
and then we fit this decay curve um
to a two exponential model because we're
looking at both the free
and bound forms of nadh and fad we also
have this instrument response function
that we first deconvolve with the
measured values
to obtain our decay curse so
i'm going to mostly talk about the mean
lifetime today
and that's the weighted average of the
short and the long lifetime so this
alpha value is just
the contribution of the free nadh or the
alpha 2 is the contribution of
the protein bound nadh and that's what
we're measuring in our experiments
we're also doing single cell analysis so
again this is autofluorescence
measurements
so we had to develop our own pipelines
for
segmenting cells specifically cell
cytoplasm so we're saying many out the
nucleus
and keeping the cytosol and mitochondria
all together
and through this we can then graph
basically the number of cells and an
autofluorescence variable and then start
to ask questions about the heterogeneity
and those populations
so i'm actually going to breeze over a
bunch of our work in just one slide here
we've done a bunch of work in vivo
and in tumor organoids derived from both
animal models and patients
and we've shown that we can combine all
of these variables in a way that makes a
little easier to understand what the
cell is thinking
so i already told you about the redox
ratio and the lifetimes of nadh and fad
which have a two exponential decay
we just did this empirically so this is
from a multivariate
analysis of variance we knew which cells
were responsive to treatment and which
weren't across multiple model systems
and we found that basically a linear
combination of the redox ratio
nadh mean lifetime and fad mean lifetime
all mean normalized with the
minus one coefficient here for the fab
provided us with really sensitive and
specific information
on cell response to treatment so
biochemically this is not as
meaningful as each variable on its own
because it's composite
but within this we know that we're
looking at the relative amounts of
electron donor and acceptor in a cell
and the enzyme activity of nadh and fad
and we define this omi index to increase
or not change
in cells that are resistant to treatment
or to decrease in cells that are
responsive to treatment
so we showed that depending on the model
system of somewhere around one to three
days post-treatment we're very sensitive
to treatment response
in organoids that predicts later in vivo
response
in mouse models and in patient samples
so for the clinical translation i really
want to highlight my clinical
collaborators dusty deming and mark
burkhard
and this fantastic program they've made
the precision medicine molecular tumor
board
so this is a wisconsin service it's
supported by the wisconsin state
government
and it is um a free referral service so
you can refer yourself or any of your
you know doctors can refer you um and
what you get is a free
genomic report so we need a biopsy or a
surgical sample and we can look for
common genetic alterations and then
the smart people on the review board
like dusty and mark get together and
look at this genomic report and then
make a recommendation so they might find
that you have a pretty typical genomic
report and you should go
on standard treatment they might find
you have a particular mutation that
makes you a really good candidate for a
clinical trial and
they might find you have a mutation that
isn't common for your cancer but is
common in other cancers so you might use
a different cancer treatment
so we have tapped into this precision
medicine molecular tumor board and some
of the samples
in which we get a genomic report we also
grow
tumor organoids and we ask questions
about whether we can predict which
treatment is best and what alternative
treatments might be best
by testing those treatments directly on
the patient samples
so i'm going to talk first about some
pancreatic cancer studies we've done
and then a little bit about some breast
cancer studies we've done but we have
ongoing studies and multiple cancer
types
so for example we have here a pancreatic
cancer patient
and the control is just given vehicle
and the
g plus f is gem cytamine and full
furanox that's a common treatment for
pancreatic cancer
and these are both organoids from a
patient uh the same patient
so they're matched and what we found is
that this patient would respond well to
the combination treatment
and they have a nice sort of homogeneous
distribution of cellular metabolism in
the control samples
and a nice homogeneous distribution of
cell metabolism in the treated samples
so this to us
looks like maybe someone who would
respond well to treatment
here is another patient patient eight um
they were prescribed five fu treatment
so i should mention the first patient
was prescribed this gem cytomine and
fulfill fulfilling ox treatment same
story here we have the control
cells and the treated cells in 3d
culture
so all the cells we're looking at here
are tumor cells
and what we see is a very low
difference between the omi index and the
control and the five fu treated
organoids
and this glasses delta is just a measure
of mean differences with respect to
standard deviation so it's a little more
strict than what you'll find from a
t-test
and what we see in the control samples
is that this is a heterogeneous response
even
a heterogeneous distribution of
metabolic activity even without
any treatment and when we do treat the
patient
sample we see a very similar
heterogeneous distribution that has not
changed
with treatment so we would predict that
this person would not do well on 5fu
treatment just based on the mean change
in the omi index
and on the heterogeneity of those
changes
so when we started these studies we
thought gee these little squiggles of
you know population density modeling
here are really useful for understanding
what's happening in the patient and
perhaps we should quantify
how these squiggles change with patients
oh i forgot to mention we also measure
you know standard measures of response
like ki 67 which is a
immunohistochemical measure of
proliferation
and clear caspase-3 which is also
immunohistochemistry of apoptosis and
we see that we have good correlation
between you know some of these like ks67
but it's not perfect um and so we're
measuring something related to
proliferation but not exactly the same
and not exactly the same as apoptosis so
it's a
useful measure but different from what
we're used to seeing
so the heterogeneity index is something
we developed
to try to understand the single cell
metabolic response that we were
observing in
our patient derived samples and we
actually
um developed this from the shannon
diversity index which is used in
information theory it's used in ecology
to understand diversity
in an ecosystem we modified it a little
bit so that it could
characterize the changes we saw and the
samples we were looking at
so really we're just looking at uh the
number of subpopulations in the sample
so one with one subpopulation is more
homogeneous than
two subpopulations equality in
sub-populations means it's more
heterogeneous
instead of like say a minority very
small sub-population
and a majority very large sub-population
a greater separation between these
sub-populations also
indicates greater heterogeneity and then
we also included a standard deviation
measure
so that we could define how broad these
subpopulations are
so overall we define this as a weighted
heterogeneity index because we
decided to add this sort of standard
deviation at the end
so it's a little different than the
shannon diversity index but it provides
similar information
so what we found in this initial study
of just
see one two three four five six seven
patients um
is that we had some who responded much
better to treatment than others so
uh the the ones we predicted to respond
are in blue
um there are actual responses indicated
at the end here
and red are those that we predicted
would not respond well to the treatment
they were prescribed
so we just arbitrarily more or less drew
this line here at 12 months which
discriminates those patients that we
predicted would respond versus those
patients we
predicted would not respond there's many
ways to design this study and this is
very small
so um we defined whether or not these
patients would respond or not based on
two things
this class index um delta which i'm
showing here the definition again is the
omi index for the control minus that of
the drug treated sample
divided by the standard deviation of
control so we tested multiple treatments
but here we're just talking about the
treatment that the patient
was actually given and then we follow
them up over time
that's what this swimmer plot's about so
you can see that the
predicted patient non-responders had a
much lower
change in their omi index compared to
those we predicted would respond to
treatment so that checks out with how we
define our omi index
in our previous studies we also
quantified the weighted heterogeneity
index which i defined here again for you
and we find that those patients who
responded to treatments they might have
had very heterogeneous tumors to begin
with
but those got much less heterogeneous
with time
or sorry with treatment uh whereas these
patients who had
a very poor response had high head
originating that did not change much
with treatment
or low heterogeneity that then increased
with treatments
so this is the first study of course and
we're looking at more patients
through the precision medicine molecular
tumor board to see if this holds
i mentioned the only response to the
tumor cells so far so
organoids are great in that they also
have other cell types so we see
stellate cells or fibroblasts growing in
the culture too
and especially adhering to the glass so
that's what we're seeing here
are the fibroblasts in these patient
derived samples
so we quantified response for these
cells as well in the hopes of finding
drugs that might target these important
cells within
pancreatic cancer so actually still
eight cells and fibroblasts can make up
as much as
80 or 90 of the tumor mass so you can
see here some of these
fibroblasts are responding very well to
the treatment in a homogeneous way
um some others are not responding very
well and
are very heterogeneous and then others
are responding well also in a
homogeneous way
so you can see that we have um you know
the middle patient here who has
the least response in their fiber blocks
had the earliest recurrence
whereas these two which responded well
to their treatment
um had longer um
life so that so far was just talking
about pancreatic cancer but we also have
some studies in breast cancer
so i wanted to show just one sort of
representative slide from breast cancer
because
this study relied only on
core needle biopsies which are very
small samples but they're valuable
samples because the core needle biopsies
are taken before neoadjuvant treatment
so then
we have a very well defined treatment
window of neoadjuvant and then surgery
so we can look at exactly how those
patients respond to treatment
so here we're using different drugs
because we are looking at breast cancer
paclitaxel on its own uh with
cyclophosphamide
and with cyclophosphamide and
doxorubicin so we looked at a few
other um drugs depending on what the
patient was expressing for example if
they had a her2-positive tumor
we gave him trustus med um but you can
see here very clearly that the
combination treatment
created the largest changes in omi index
in the
patient drive tumor organized if we just
look at a couple of examples this is one
patient who had a very
good response to their prescribed
treatment in their organoids and it was
very homogeneous response
and at the time of surgery the
pathologist indicated that this patient
had minimum residual disease that agrees
well with
these large changes we saw in their
organoids
here we have another patient who
actually had extensive
residual disease at the time of surgery
when we looked at their
tumor organoids for their prescribed
treatment they had
smaller glasses delta it's a smaller
change in omi index with treatment
and they had a more heterogeneous tumor
before treatment so again this is only a
few patients and we're trying to
put all this data together but that
gives us an indication of what might be
the path for breast cancer assessments
especially in the neoadjuvant setting
so i just mentioned today a few patients
from pancreatic cancer and breast cancer
and i really only talked about the
clinical studies we have
many more studies in mouse models of
cancer too
so we're trying to reconcile what's
happening in patients with what we see
in mice and we're trying to understand
what particular parameters
are most predictive of treatment
response we're looking
as well at oral cancer neuroendocrine
tumors and colon cancers
and this is all again through the
precision medicine molecular tumor board
at the university of wisconsin in
madison
so today i talked a little bit about
single cell adaptation in
cancer and hopefully i've convinced you
that this is an important feature to
look at
both pre-clinically for drug development
and clinically for informing
patient treatment decisions and we
looked at a few examples of
patient-matched organoids
in both pancreatic cancer and breast
cancer
to understand whether cellular metabolic
heterogeneity can
explain some of our treatment response
in the clinic
and we're hoping that we could use this
method to predict patient treatment
response and develop more effective
therapies for patients
i'd like to thank especially joe sharik
who did
all the work in the breast cancer and
pancreatic cancer
my collaborators of course um dusty
deming mark percard
sherry patch and all the wonderful
people i work with at the university of
wisconsin
and i'm happy to take any questions and
thank you
hi kyle how are you
well thank you melissa uh for that talk
and let's move on to the q a
portion um so we have a question about
image analysis we can maybe start with
that
for uh segmentation of single nuclei
in the uh organoid structure you
mentioned that you're using ai
could you talk a little bit more about
this in in detail
yeah i actually um we're not really
using ai so we're using cell profiler
which is a
free wear you know out of the broad
institute
um and it is um
you know identifying an object which is
the nuclei and then
once we get to the nuclei it propagates
out until it identifies the um
cell border so it's not it's not ai
but we are working on more methods
because um
it isn't perfect and we have to go in
there and fix stuff often
so we're also looking at um
convolutional neural networks and
you know we're getting those to work
real well in cells that are sparse
but as soon as they start to get close
and start to touch like they do in
organoids you know we're having some
trouble so
we're running the cnns and then adding
more on top of that um
but it's not perfect yet so we're still
relying on the cell profiler pipelines
so moving on to some questions that we
have about
the the culture conditions is there
selection pressure for the cells which
grow out
under the organic conditions that you
provide and do all the
cells in the tumor sample grow up yeah
that's a super cool question because
it actually speaks to one of the
advantages of organoid so what we find
when we do like genetic hot spot
sequencing on the organoids is that we
have much cleaner data
than we do from the original tumor
sample and that is because we do select
for
tumor cells within the culture rather
than um
a large degree of stromal cells mostly
is what we're keeping out
just based on the culture conditions and
then further what we're finding i wish i
had the image to show you is that
if you look at a plate of organoids and
you look at say the redox ratio of them
you'll see some
that are much lower than others and you
can actually pipette them out
and then sequence those and you'll find
that those are the subclones
um so it's a really cool way to be able
to
identify subclones and then actually
isolate them and then ask how they
differ
i think i answered the question i kind
of went off the rails there yeah
so we have yeah a few uh sort of
clarification questions
when you perform the assays and
treatments do you keep the organizer
tumorides within the ecm or remove them
from the ecm
uh yes we do remove them from the ecm
and then we put them in a matrigel or
collagen matrix depending on the
protocol
most people are using matrigel which i
know
isn't fantastic because you know that's
the batch variation and it has all kinds
of unknowns in it but that's what is the
current standard protocol
um we do try to keep you know with
culture conditions we can keep t cells
in there you just have to add cytokine
um you can keep fibroblasts i showed you
um
and other cell types will grow in there
you just have to have the right things
in your media if you want those
yeah okay so one looks like we have
time for one last question um how
quickly can you scale the organized from
the time that you receive them from the
patients
to conducting these these assays ah
right so the time i think we um
used to just get the biopsy and then
within three days
we would like we would treat them almost
immediately and then two days later
assess treatment response
uh but working with some other
collaborators they prefer to passage the
organoid so they might wait seven to ten
days before giving the drug
and then the stuffing responds so again
it depends on what your goals
are um if you want to retain more of the
original tumor cells or if you want to
select for those more
um pure population
well thank you very much melissa for the
talk and answering uh these questions
and thank you all for participating
yeah fun stuff thank you